troisième volet de notre série consacrée
au un an du conflit en Ukraine ce soir
on s'intéresse aux mesures
d'accompagnement mise en place pour
aider les réfugiés à prendre le français
un passage nécessaire pour s'intégrer et
trouver un emploi la région en lien avec
Pôle Emploi propose régulièrement des
cours intensifs pour adultes Florent
Clavel a assisté à l'un d'entre eux à
Loches
[Musique]
Maria 22 ans est arrivée de Kiev il y a
presque un an avec sa mère Roxana et
comme elle le confie à sa professeure ce
matin-là elle sait déjà plutôt bien
intégrée qu'est-ce que tu as préféré à
Paris
j'aimerais voir avec un bon un bel homme
première histoire
avec un bel homme un an de guerre mais
toujours la vie qui surgit et c'est ce
qui fait le succès de ses cours de
français dispensés à Loches ce groupe
dukrainienne s'y rend quasi
quotidiennement après trois mois
d'apprentissage les niveaux sont encore
disparate mais la volonté est là elles
vont avoir en général une compréhension
assez bonne
grâce aux français grâce au cours de
français mais aussi parce qu'en fait
elles ont elles sont en immersion pour
certaines ça va être plus compliqué en
fait de s'exprimer parce qu'elles n'ont
pas forcément fait beaucoup d'études ou
parce que elles ont plus de difficultés
tout simplement étudiantes en sociologie
en Ukraine Maria d'abord a pris le
français grâce à des courants en ligne
aujourd'hui quasiment bilingue elle
espère bien profiter de cet atout j'ai
appris le français pour pour m'intégrer
et pour être pour être bien ici et pour
travailler bien sûr
pour ces femmes un moment de déconnexion
une bulle de tranquillité même si dans
les esprits la guerre n'est jamais loin
je voudrais très
très
chaud
certaines de ces ukrainiennes pourront
travailler dès la fin des cours prévus
cette semaine en attendant de pouvoir
rentrer dans leur pays
[Musique]